2014 was said to be the air for
stumbling pc launches but it seems like
2015 is following suit as well Andy bam
and kevin van word where to talk about
batman arkham knight md i want to talk
to you about the pc stuff and a little
bit but first 11 we haven't had a chance
to talk since the review enter through
the week III yea rather busy and we gave
a 7 out of 10 some people were
displeased with that to say the least
and people displease especially before
the game actually came out yes that's 12
i was uh in the five days before I
actually got a chance to play it
actually put this on my trilogy of thing
of reviews I've gotten the most hate for
i wanna so i think i think that oh god
what were the other as he say human or
was one in resin evil 6 was the other
people gave [ __ ] to you for a human a
lot why I would say that makes up my
trilogy of stuff that for whatever
reason I had the most amount of like
brought directly to me on Twitter and an
email and very loving so let's bring it
in Resident Evil was up was a total
piece of [ __ ] but what did you put for
toyota 45 k fact yeah that sense yeah I
don't think time through working right
on that yeah to human had like problems
like for instance the five minutes it
took for the Valkyrie calm down
everybody about that one was ish number
one because the footage which I didn't
take I wasn't playing the in the footage
so some of the footage um the person who
is playing it there was a bunch there
were in the video review there was a
bunch of like my armor this is work to
human here too bad the other the other
thing is kevin Pereira uh did a video
blog um bashing my review all really
that in turn led to one of giant bombs
early videos which was a rap video that
was basically them rapping to uh kevin
Pereira vs kevin van org and I mean I've
never even met Kevin prayer spoke with
him but it was it was quite the thing at
the time was good times then obviously
this one you know I think maybe the
difference is that like seven out of
town gamespot is a pretty great it's
good yeah I mean I do like you enjoyed
the game I did I did yes so what did you
like and what what did you have
exception well the things I liked with
the things that sort of carried over
from Arkham City
arm moving when you're not in the
Batmobile moving is one of the best
things I in terms of just like pure joy
of movement I don't think any game
really gets it better then uh then than
these games there myself Assassin's
Creed fun yeah I mean as much as I love
assassin creed i would even say you know
i mean at this stage I mean uh even even
I'm a little tired of Assassin's Creed
but um for Batman I don't think there's
really any game that makes moving
through a city more enjoyable than this
I mean look at that you're back you're
floating through the city and then when
you get the when you get the hook out
and you're just thrusting yourself
through the city especially that when I
when I leveled up that was one of the
first things I was leveling up to get
that like trilogy like hitting the
button three times and launching
yourself really fast like that's that's
the good stuff and of course the UM the
predator rooms where you're basically
it's it's you when a bunch of dudes and
you get to use all your gadgets and your
fists and whatever else is the sort of
as you are training type mini thing is
it well what I what I when I more media
I mean I mean I guess there are some
training some some AR things for
predators but I mean just like whenever
the whenever the mission takes you to a
place and you have to you have to get
rid of everybody regardless of how you
do it um whether you beat them up but
sometimes you can't really do that
because they've got guns and evening you
just got to use your tools to your best
ability that stuff is really good um and
the detecting stuff my favorite stuff
was the detective stuff a few a few of
those were just like wrote like the
murder mysteries more likely you just do
the same thing four times in a row kind
of thing well I've not played by and
I've not played arkham knight but I've
played the old ones and a lot of what
you're talking about sounds like stuff
that they have it's like well trodden
Granicus yeah they did really well in
the old games yeah totally uh and I
still think that Arkham Asylum is one of
the best games of of this type ever made
it's not an open-world game obviously
but I still think it's one of the best
you know just action adventures and what
it brought was amazing so uh and and III
I would say though that I think that
arkham city is is pretty much the
superior game to Arkham Knight um so
some of it is yeah you know they've
they've trod this ground
for so before we get into the pc stuff
what was what were the things you sort
of took exception with I've been hearing
the story isn't is great in the
Batmobile stuff can get a bit right well
one of the that's that's the biggest for
me the biggest thing was the the
Batmobile and I and I think that even
now I think that people the play this
game can divide themselves into two
camps liking them you know liking the
Batmobile or not liking the Batmobile
actually driving the Batmobile this
stuff that you're seeing on the screen
now is my favorite stuff with the
Batmobile when you get to speed along
when you get to actually be in a bet
when we land use it as a as a vehicle on
the tank stuff on the other hand can get
it's not so bad on its own but the game
really relies on it so you especially
towards the end of the game you're just
doing all this tank stuff over and over
again it doesn't really fall you're
doing the same basic thing from
beginning the game to the end of the
game with that stuff the other stuff too
is the way that it's just shoehorn into
every puzzle and every if you have to
use it yeah there's a lot of stuff where
you have to use the Batmobile and it
leads to some some tedium like one of
the first things you do is you have to
get into a chemical plant you have to
get it yeah everybody loves a good crane
puzzle in a video yeah right so you have
to like use the crane to move the ramp
and then you have to go back and use the
crane and move the ramp again now you
have to use the Cray to move the ramp
again and and so it's just like a lot of
that stuff and to me some of the the
puzzle stuff that the Batmobile just got
really tedious especially because you
can see like hey most of the time I
should be able to grapple to that bit
right but now you're taking that away
from me because you have the thing you
want to do with the Batmobile and that
wasn't my proudest moment regardless of
some of the things you didn't enjoy 7
Thank great review and you can read it
on gamespot com right now and what I
want to talk about is something that
happened to fall out afterwards
obviously you reviewed on PlayStation 4
is all right yeah I totally reviewed
Batman on ps4 that was the only version
that we were given yes so the pc stuff
sort of happened after the fact and so
as everyone's probably more than aware
now and once the game came out series of
massive problems on the pc between
performance issues and just crashing and
one of the patch has already come out
and just to read some of the patch notes
gives you an idea of just how bad some
of the problems were so what they fixed
was support
for frame rates above 30 frames per
second they put that into the graphics
menu have fixed for low resolution
texture bugs improve overall performance
add more options to graphic settings
improvements the hard drive streaming in
hitches addresses to full screen
rendering and there was a problem with
Nvidia's sli there was a problem with
AMD crossfire and and also they updated
the drivers for both AMD and NVIDIA so
this is there's a lot of stuff there's
actually more on this list and you've
been playing on PC and the you and meri
actually were recording at gamespot
plays just over here on Friday and you
actually encountered a bunch of bugs
then and there right yeah now you say
they fix problems that have to do with
SLI maybe those are made in problem yeah
because we're running a triple SLI on
that machine and there was points where
it just would hard crash every time it
was it was like what were you like
jumping the Batmobile in a certain
mission it's like and just dumps just
crash the data and then once we turned
off some settings and that you know
there's like three or four nvidia
settings if anybody's seen it it's like
more fog and more papers flying on the
streets and it's like it's not hair
works but you know same sort of deal and
would turn those off and we got further
in the game yeah got a little further
and then a car crash again oh really I
know and then here we are looking at the
graphics of stuff cuz yeah it's it looks
good on PC we don't realize that you're
actually missing textures until you
compare its I'm a pirate suddenly like
why should the console version look
better you guys are more detail on the
brakes of the Batmobile why I'm like
I've noticed a lot of panels that Batman
like rips off stuff has like no texture
his cape has like weird textures on the
pc like it's all it's all sort of there
if you know what to look for so that's
the weird thing it's like this is almost
like an ignorance is bliss here thing
it's like the internet age suddenly you
can't get away a machine texture yeah
because you know there are like high-res
graphics comparisons up before you know
what's going on yeah that was a
recording of our progress that's about
what we saw like five or six times but
anyway I've been running on the pc here
work too with only one graphics card at
97 gtx 970 uh pretty good and I even
this was pre patch I've been running at
60 cuz I like tweak that ini file it's
like max frame rate 30 i put it like 11
50 and and let it go and it's been
running really well but actually
I think your score kevin is a little
generous like seven really because like
what you said it like the the best parts
of the stuff that carries over from the
original right and there isn't enough
that screens driving me crazy by the way
now that I yeah when I know that I know
the battle be look at the missing
textures on the Batmobile it's so weird
anyway anyway the center carries over
there isn't enough there's like hardly
any predator moments yeah they they
really do take away a lot of stuff that
I think is the best part of it yeah you
know it's interesting because then
people say oh then you would have been
you know complaining because it was just
the same thing over and over again maybe
I don't know like I don't know what
hypothetical game that yeah man arkham
knight without the Batmobile would have
been and it's like the Batmobile is
broken like it though no it's like it
great yeah it feels fight it's just like
do you really want to sit there in a
batman game moving your tank every once
in a while to dodge telegraph shots and
then [ __ ] like no yeah [ __ ] no i want a
bike play against villains like that's
what's so great about the first thing is
so many good villains there's so many
good like really big levels you go
through to i get to the villain like
it's set up like an episodic thing
almost and it's like awesome and this
one it's like oh go find the penguin and
it's like one little building and then
you go punch the penguin anyway there's
like no bill I think this I do think
that the story is a little bit of a
problem in this game because the the
things that the things that you're most
supposed to care about one of one of
which is supposedly is the Arkham
Knights identity the game for shadows it
so strongly for so long that by the time
like there's there's no fun to the
moment the mask comes off because you're
like whatever like you already know
what's coming and that's the same for
most of the story points for me I mean
I've seen a lot of other people you know
complaining about how you know how it
used the killing joke in a very poor way
and then kind of stuff and I don't
really have much of a feeling about that
particular portion but I do have
feelings about other you know other
story stuff here which is to say I just
I was much more involved with I still
love the Arkham Asylum story a whole lot
great a great series the Rockstar
developed over the past any rocks are
you rock steady with he'll get help on
one of them yeah but it's a it's it's
all wrapped up now so it'll be great to
see them work on something else yeah cuz
let them like about the game
yeah totally to it's beautiful and me as
well and but in the end if somebody were
to ask me you know I'd say just you just
play arkham city again if you like that
style or buy it on Steam and if it
doesn't work thankfully they've put in
that new and refund problem if it
doesn't work yeah once its back on steam
as a backup and steam I don't know I
don't know I can official announcement
yeah I guess we'll find out pretty soon
yeah yeah so that's it Andy and Kevin
thank you so much for coming up talking
Batman